Okay--let's learn about another input type.
I'm going to change our main input
from type="password" to type="checkbox".
And this, as you might imagine, will make a checkbox.
When we go to our form, I hit Reload,
and now we have a checkbox next to our Submit button.
When I check this checkbox--you know--
a checkbox is for toggling something on and off--I'm sure you've seen them before.
When I check this checkbox and hit Submit,
we see in our URL the "q" parameter equals "on".
That means that the box was checked.
What happens--and you can try this yourself--
when I hit Submit, when the checkbox isn't checked?
Is it off, the parameter doesn't appear at all,
the parameter is blank
or is it the string, "hunter2"?